now region breaks everything about this  day is so awkward I feel like I want to  die right now I'm so embarrassed  but if on the other man Shay's is very  chiseled  he has this like sexy thing going he's  like dripping with sweat he's like this  cat you didn't know you had there's like  an attraction there for sure okay guys  we're gonna demonstrate okay something  called yab YUM it's yes yeah yes a bunny  named yep yep young yeah right step step  Rock step step time more time five six  seven eight oh  damn step 7 yeah  dancing is not easy I will tell you that  probably the world's worst and I don't  know that I'm mr. cool to begin with  step down I just hope JoJo's looking for  a normal guy like me